foreign
[Music]
our top story Matt Hancock says he is
profoundly sorry at the covert inquiry
but is given the cold shoulder by
bereaved families
I am profoundly sorry for the impact
that had I'm profoundly sorry for each
death that has occurred
the conservative London may all hopeful
Daniel corski denies groping a woman
during a meeting at number 10.
reframing the Rebellion Putin Praises
his troops for averting a Civil War and
confirms the Wagner group was heavily
funded by the Kremlin
also tonight not a game for all a
damning report condemns Cricket as
racist sexist and far too elitist
as a sport we need to learn from plus
mistakes and do all we can to make
people feel safe and be themselves at
every level
[Music]
Nicola Bully's family say they are still
receiving online abuse after a coroner
finds her death was an accident
Donald Trump has heard discussing a
secret official document in a recording
which forms part of the case against him
no I can't you know but this is yeah
human remains found in mountains in
California are confirmed to be those of
the British actor Julian Sands
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening Matt Hancock
was shunned by bereaved families today
as he took his turn at the official
covert inquiry the former Health
secretary said he was profoundly sorry
for the impact caused by kovid but
acknowledged that his apology would be
hard to take for some he was also
scathing about the UK's plans to prepare
for a pandemic saying there was far too
much focus on how to dispose of the Dead
rather than save lives a health
correspondent Ashish Joshi reports
Matt Hancock would have known his first
appearance of the covert inquiry would
be difficult
but not as difficult as for the bereaved
families he walked past on his way into
the hearing
the evidence I shall give
shall be the truth
the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
his line of defense
defense darts he blamed the system his
fault was to believe what he had been
told about the country's Readiness I was
assured that the UK planning was
among the best and in some instances the
best in the world the attitude the
doctrine of the UK
was to plan
for the consequences of a disaster
can we buy enough body bags where are we
going to bury the dead
and that was completely wrong
why were those practical
considerations not followed through
these recommendations were not there
because the system was geared towards
how to how to clear up after a disaster
not prevented
from testing to PPE to social care every
failure was according to Mr Hancock
systemic
when Matt Hancock walked through these
doors in 2018 as the new health
secretary warnings about an emerging
pandemic had already been sounded but he
says he inherited a flawed Health System
one that was worried about Mass
casualties and body bags and burial
space not with containing the spread of
the virus but there was more than one
attempt at an apology from Mr Hancock
his written submission when he said
there isn't a day that goes by that I do
not think about all those who lost their
lives to this awful disease
and again in person
I am profoundly sorry for the impact
that had I'm profoundly sorry for each
death that has occurred and I also
understand
why for some it will be
hard to take that apology from me
but for bereaved Widow Lorelei King
the apology means nothing I don't accept
his apology and most of the brief well
all of the brief that was sitting with
won't accept his apology either
lauralee's husband Vincent died in March
2021 after catching covid in a care home
the same Care Home Matt Hancock visited
before the pandemic she was with other
bereaved families where Mr Hancock
approached them after he gave evidence I
felt surprised it just really confirmed
for me the arrogance of the man
to think that such an overture would be
welcome
because it isn't and it wasn't
as evidenced by the fact that we all
turned our backs on here
[Music]
Matt Hancock comes back in the Autumn
when the inquiry turns its focus to his
and other senior roles at the heart of
the government's pandemic decision
making
oh she's Joshi Sky News
one of the people in the running to be
the Conservative candidate for the mayor
of London has denied accusations that he
groped a woman Inside 10 Downing Street
his accused of the television producer
Daisy Goodwin has tried to make a formal
complaint Mr korski has also claimed
that conservative officials were aware
of the allegations when he launched his
campaign our political correspondent
Murray Aurora has this report
claiming to be able to take London in a
new direction is it time for you to
stand out from the normal race she's
basically
Tori mayor hopeful Daniel corski's
campaign has been rocked by serious
allegations of sexual misconduct
in 2013 novelist and screenwriter Daisy
Goodwin met korski at 10 Downing Street
where he was a special adviser to David
Cameron where she claims he sexually
assaulted her by putting his hand on her
breast corski has categorically denied
assaulting Goodwin they didn't do what's
been alleged I absolutely didn't do that
10 years ago when it happened nothing
was said to me seven years ago when this
first came out nobody alleged anything
to me I just didn't do what's being
alleged the kind of place where
everybody can afford their home and
where everybody can walk home safely at
night but especially women no official
Complaint has been made and conservative
Campaign Headquarters has said it will
not investigate the allegation I
understand a serious allegation has been
made regarding Mr corski I also
understand a formal complaint hasn't
been made Mr pulski himself has replied
with a personal statement to that
allegation earlier today okay so Mr
Koski has commented on it obviously it's
a serious issue and it's right that is
commented on it but
understands Tori MP Robert Halpin has
paused his support for corsky to become
London mayor
other candidates won't be drawn on
whether Koski ought to drop out of the
race altogether it's up to him he is
running his campaign I'm running mine I
desperately want to win I want to take
on Sadiq Khan and that's that's the
beginning and the end of it I can take
on a big city card
so what I've talked about as the London
green his commitment to his campaign
remains steadfast but if corski
continues to lose support from his
conservative backers these allegations
may prove fatal to his chances in the
race
Mari Aurora Sky News Westminster
escamona from our political
correspondent Liz Bates who's at a
conservative headquarters what's likely
to happen now Liz
[Music]
well this is a story that has progressed
very quickly throughout the day quite
clear I think that Daniel korski is very
much trying to cling on to his political
career we've had a number of statements
from his spokesman from him he did an
interview in which he repeatedly said
that he denies this allegation in the
strongest possible terms so the question
now is is either the conservative party
or number 10 going to do anything now
that this allegation has come to light
now both of them saying today that there
are processes in place there are codes
of conduct but no investigation has been
launched and as of this evening it looks
like there probably won't be one the
conservative party we're outside the
headquarters this evening they were
saying this morning no investigation
what has transpired in that interview
with Mr Koski is that they already knew
that he was connected to this allegation
because he told them himself and had
already chosen to do nothing now what we
also know this evening is that Daisy
Goodwin has now attempted because she's
told the Times newspaper to put in a
formal complaint to the cabinet office
in an attempt to trigger a formal
investigation but what we understand is
that the cabinet officers complaints
process probably wouldn't apply to a
retrospect a retrospective complaint of
this nature so the uh really now or the
only people that we're looking at in
terms of Daniel corski's future in the
Mayoral race are his supporters well
most of them today have been keeping
their heads down some of them privately
concerned that he doesn't have a future
in this race but no no public
distancing of themselves from Daniel
corski so today he is defiant he remains
in the race and the conservative party
and number 10 taking no action
Liz Bates thank you
to Russia now where in his third public
address in just 24 hours President Putin
thanked troops for preventing what he
described as civil war the leader of
Belarus confirmed that the man who'd
threatened to march on Moscow yevgeni
progression has finally arrived there
meanwhile Ukraine's counter-offensive
continues with signs that territory not
held since 2014 is being recaptured her
International Affairs editor Dominic
wyckorn reports with Russia reeling in
the wake of its armed Mutiny on the
outskirts of bakmut its enemies are
trying to take advantage
ukrainians claim to be pushing back into
the city taken by Russia's varg The
Mercenaries before they turned Rogue
their Revolt over the weekend has made
Russia's president look weak the gravest
threat yet to his rule he's trying now
to project strength appearing with his
Security Forces who fail to foresee and
stop the Rebellion against him and he
admitted that Civil War had been on the
cards
you defended the Constitutional order
lives security and freedom of our
citizens saved our motherland from
upheavals and effectively stopped a
civil war later he took ownership of
Wagner with this account of its support
from his government the government has
fully funded the Wagner group while the
vulgar group allowance was on the
government's shoulders concord's owner
earned 80 billion rubles over the year
through voyantogs by providing food and
catering services to the military still
no sign of the man who took all that
money after calling off his Uprising
Wagner's mutinous leader Evgeni
pregosian has now arrived in Belarus
the question now can his fighters who
took control of at least two major
Russian cities over the weekend now join
him Belarusian dictator Alexander
lukashenko has also been in front of the
cameras after brokering the deal that
defused the Mutiny it was perhaps a sign
of Putin's waning power that even a man
regarded as his puppet seemed to be
criticizing him
the cruel decision was made to eliminate
pregosian it sounded that way between
the lines of Putin's speech I suggested
to Putin not to rush meanwhile Putin's
enemies are claiming advances on the
fields of battle their forces
counter-offensive apparently picking up
steam analysts say Ukraine is making
some progress the ukrainians are
reclaiming some territories in some
cases those that they lost in 2014 and
although these are not big areas these
are actually big psychological gains
because it shows that the ukrainians are
serious in saying we want all of our
territory back they've got a long way to
go yet but getting some of it back is
gives them heart and will not go down
very well in Moscow they are so far only
modest advances against the Russian
Invader but the more successful the
Ukrainian counter-offensive the more
acute Vladimir Putin's pain Dominic
wagorn Sky News Kiev Ukraine
NHS Consultants have voted to go on
strike on July the 20th and 21st in a
dispute overpay but a ballot of the
Royal College of nurses in England has
decided not to continue industrial
action after the union did not meet the
required number of votes to enable
further action
policing California Southern California
have confirmed that remains found at the
weekend were those of the British actor
Julian Sands for the cause of death
isn't yet known he'd been missing since
January when he failed to return from a
hike Sans had roles in films including A
Room With a View The Killing Fields And
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo he was
65.
[Music]
[Applause]
Aunt Louis Capaldi has announced he is
taking a break from touring for the
foreseeable future it comes after he
struggled to finish his performance at
Glastonbury he says he's still learning
to adjust to the impact of his
Tourette's and needs time to focus on
his physical and mental health
the family of Nicola bully have hit out
at speculation on social media following
her death as an inquest found she
drowned accidentally family members said
she'd been looking forward to the future
and had overcome difficulties with
alcohol and anxiety Martin brunt reports
after all the wild speculation and
conspiracy theories the coroner ruled
that Nicola Bully's death was an
accident
she tumbled into the river probably down
this steep bank and drowned it wasn't a
crime it wasn't suicide said the coroner
but exactly why she fell in is still a
mystery
Nicholas body was recovered from the
water at some Michael's on wire three
weeks later
after the verdict a solicitor spoke for
Nicholas family
once we'll never forget the loss of our
Nikki we will forever remember her as
the brilliant mum
partner
daughter and sister that we all knew and
loved so very much it's upsetting that
we've continued to receive
negative targeted messages
I'm still widely inaccurate speculation
being shared on numerous platforms
the coroner had been so worried about
disruption to the inquest that police
patrolled around the building he said
there have been threats of protests
inside and out
the inquest heard that Nicola had
struggled with the effects of the
menopause had alcohol issues and
suffered from anxiety her sister Louise
said she was so worried she'd called a
mental health emergency team two weeks
before Nicola vanished it worked as a
wake-up call Nicola stopped drinking
Nicholas partner Paul Ansel told the
coroner she had recently turned her life
around
he said the blip over the Christmas
period happened but in January she was
back to herself looking forward to the
future and everything was on the up
we were good together I offered her
spontaneity and she was the planner she
was an incredible mum
the coroner was told that at the time
she vanished Nicola was excited by her
work prospects she was planning a spa
day and arranging a playdate for her
daughter nobody who saw her that morning
thought there was anything wrong with
her
Nicholas family said they took comfort
in messages from strangers around the
world one day they said Nicholas two
daughters will read the many cards
filled with such kindness and love
Martin brunt Sky News Preston
now tomorrow England will set foot on
the hallowed Turf of Lords for the start
of the second ashes test but today
Captain Ben Stokes apologized after a
damning report found racism and sexism
widespread in the sport the independent
commission for equity in cricket says
deep rooted class barriers and making
the sport elitist and exclusionary and
called for Urgent reform our Sports
correspondent Rob Harris has this report
away from the Grandeur of Lords this is
where Cricket is already producing
Solutions on a pitch in style Bridge a
pathway being provided into the
professional game for British Asian
players in a system found to be Rife
with inequalities and discrimination
players who are questioning why there
are opportunities with County sides
prove so short-lived I think when you're
young and you're growing up from when
you're 10 to wherever when you're
playing Asia quicker you don't really
bat an eyelid at it that's kind of what
you brought up with and you think that's
just another one of those things but I
think the older you get you kind of
slowly start to realize that's not okay
before playing today they were all
digesting the cricket commission report
that's documented a deep-rooted racist
sexist and elitist culture in their
sport it's gone unchallenged too often
and can be hard to challenge it's hard
to bullet point what's the reasons why
people don't get opportunities but
there's always underlining factors where
before people were like nah it probably
doesn't exist but after the reports have
come out they clearly do we've got the
greatest series going on in the ashes
and it was just very unfortunate the
timing of this statement have come out
now when the second test starts tomorrow
but England led by Captain Ben Stokes
are committing to helping Cricket become
more inclusive
to the people involved in the game who
have been made to feel unwelcome or
unaccepted in the past I'm deeply sorry
to hear of your experiences qriket is a
game that needs to celebrate diversity
on all fronts because without diversity
this game would not be where it is at
today all while leveling gender pay
disparities to England's women can earn
a fifth of their male counterparts a pay
Gap the commission wants closing some of
those structural issues we were
surprised to hear about
including the disparities in the way in
which women are treated the lack of
investment in the game albeit it's
improved but still a lack of investment
women seen as second-class Citizens
England being crazy about Cricket
there's a mad rush of youngsters to
Lords to see Oxford and Cambridge pay
their annual match the commission wants
an end to elitist advantages like this
long-standing annual games at Lords
between Eaton and Harrow and Oxford and
Cambridge some other schools in England
it's difficult for them to play cricket
because they are inner city schools they
have the space and all that the game has
got to be inclusive but not just putting
the world inclusive people have got to
feel that they are welcome in the game
it's places like here that provide the
solution to Cricket's diversity problem
the commission found that players might
have the talent but they often fall out
of the professional game the South Asian
Cricket Academy is providing a way back
in with a platform for players to
Showcase their skills against County
second elevens they won't be put off by
entrenched discrimination faced by more
than 80 percent of commission
respondents of Asian Heritage
eradicating the hate and leveling the
playing field could take years with
English Cricket needing a reset after
its racism Reckoning Rob Harris Sky News
stourbridge
Donald Trump has been heard rifling
through papers and admitting that he had
not Declassified a highly confidential
document founded his Florida home a
recording has emerged which appears to
show Trump discussing a plan to attack
Iran and threatens to undermine the
former president's defense against the
criminal charges he faces here's our U.S
correspondent James Matthews
[Music]
another day another speech another
attack on his accusers I said wait a
minute I'm a candidate you're arresting
a candidate yeah because you're leading
that's why we're arresting if you were
losing or if you weren't a candidate
would have no problem
it was as close as Donald Trump came to
addressing his Miami court case after
the emergence of an audio tape it
contains private remarks that go to the
heart of his prosecution on the
mishandling of sensitive documents
seized from his Florida home he said he
wanted to attack Iran
this was done by the military given to
me this is audio of trump speaking about
an apparent U.S government plan to
attack Iran
he was in conversation at his Bedminster
golf course with two staff members a
writer and a publisher each with
questions over their security clearance
on tape you hear the sound of shuffling
paper
significantly Trump seems to acknowledge
he's in possession of classified
material that he couldn't declassify
thank you everybody Trump has dismissed
the material relating to Iran as the
contents of newspapers and magazines his
prosecutors would beg to differ
content that they have on audio tape a
recording of a criminal and his crime
James Matthews Sky News in Washington
let's just bring you some breaking news
now and Darren Hall who is 36 has been
charged with the murder of Sarah Henshaw
whose body was found in a lay-by near
the M1 on Monday that is according to
Derbyshire Constable constabulary she
was 31 years old last seen at her home
in ilkston on the 20th of June
now England have begun their training
camp ahead of next month's Women's World
Cup with the tournament being held in
Australia and a number of key players
missing through injury the lionesses
face a tougher Prospect than last year's
home turf victory in the Euros before
they fly down London next week Becky
Johnson went to meet the team
as they prepare to head out to the World
Cup these are the players who'll carry
the hopes of a Nation with them if the
lionesses can go all the way it'll be
the first time England have won the
World Cup since 1966. so as the players
faced the Press there was one big
question can you bring the World Cup
home
we're going to make sure we're the best
prepared we possibly can be going into
this tournament it's you know the
biggest stage in football and there's
um yeah you're playing against the
world's top team so it's definitely
going to be a challenge but like I said
all we can do is make sure we're the
best prepared and we go out there and
play our hearts out as always
it does feel that if any team can do it
they can raising the trophy as European
Champions last summer they won the
support and respect of the nation they
go into the World Cup among the
favorites having come close before but
have faced setbacks with injuries ruling
out some of the Stars Captain Leah
Williamson Beth Mead and Fran Kirby of
course we do have some great players out
of the squad but we also have some great
players in the squad and I think it
gives opportunities to others to step up
and show what they can do as well so I
think we try and focus on what we do
have here and and the depth that we have
in the squad is incredible
many of the lionesses became household
names last summer and since then the
profile of the women's game has
undoubtedly risen but they go into the
world cup with women's pay still falling
far behind men's
it's going to take a long time the fight
will keep happening we'll keep fighting
him like the Pioneers before us did to
to even enable me to stand in this
position right now like England's men
back in 66 the win last year was on home
turf at Wembley it's great what we did
for women women in sport last year and
women's football of course and it's
about making those memories again
they'll head off to Australia and New
Zealand knowing no England football team
has ever won a major championship abroad
but these lionesses have taught us to
Dare To Dream Becky Johnson Sky News at
St George's Park